lesbos samos les plus grands bidonvilles
d'europe on désert de prison à ciel
ouvert
bordée par la mer egée sur ces îles
grecques près de quatorze mille réfugiés
continuent de vivre dans des conditions
extrêmes environnement sanitaire
déplorable surpopulation attente
interminable une situation infernale
dénoncée par le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés
confrontés à cette crise humanitaire la
commissaire européenne aux affaires
intérieures a fait le déplacement
jusqu'à lesbos le motif de sa visite
poussé le gouvernement grec à accélérer
l'ouverture de nouveaux camps sur ces
îles et ce avec l'aide de l'union
européenne
[Musique]
certaines ils ont été soumises à des
normes pression en l'absence de solution
européenne
nous devons européaniser la question de
la migration nous soutenir les uns les
autres et ne laisser aucun état membre
où aucune il seul calais
l'union européenne a annoncé qu'elle
allait débloquer une enveloppe de 276
millions d'euros pour aider à la
construction de campement le ministre
grec des affaires étrangères a lui
annoncé que le nouveau camp de samos
ouvrirait à la fin du premier trimestre
une décision qui se heurte néanmoins à
l'opposition des habitants et des
autorités locales qui font face à
l'arrivée massive de réfugiés
depuis la crise migratoire de 2015 dans
le même temps bruxelles et les autorités
grecques lance un appel à la turquie la
pressent de réadmettre sur son
territoire les migrants déboutés du
droit d'asile sur le sol grec
nous avons proposé la turquie de
reprendre le retour des personnes qui
n'ont pas le droit à une protection il y
à 1450 personnes qui résident
actuellement sur ces îles
je pense que c'est une très bonne
occasion pour la turquie de démontrer sa
volonté de coopérer avec l'union
européenne et de respecter la
déclaration commune ces îles surchargé
de demandeurs d'asile ne sont qu à 15
kilomètres du rivage turc
en attendant l'aide d'ankara une
pratique semble se développer chez les
garde-côtes
gracq le push back le refoulement des
migrants vers les eaux territoriales de
la turquie une manoeuvre illégale que la
commissaire européenne aux affaires
intérieures n'a pas manqué de soulever
du côté des autorités grecques on
continue de nier ces allégations
nous n'avons pas renvoyer deux bateaux
nous avons empêché du navire d'entrer
sur le territoire européen et grec et
ses quelque chose d'autoriser par les
règlements tandis que chaque partie se
renvoient la balle face à cette crise
humanitaire qui met les frontières au
défi une tentative de dialogue se
dessine
la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen ainsi
que le président du conseil européen
charles michel se rendront à ankara le 6
avril pour rencontrer le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan